a fallen Kingdom an old war and a
familiar curse this is dark souls 2 law
everything we know so far like with all
my low video z' I'm going to interpret
the law in my own way and I'll tell you
what I'm almost certain the game will be
about so I'm not a hundred percent sure
about everything but again like my law
videos I wouldn't even try to interpret
it unless what I said was backed up by
actual evidence links to the sources are
in the description so go through it and
draw your own conclusions to my current
belief is that Dark Souls 2 takes place
many years after the chosen undead story
so far in the future that the events of
the past are legend or at least a
distant memory drangleic been a pile of
rubble suits the war thought long long
ago in the gyre crushed to shame
according to this dialogue the Giants
crossed the sea long ago so who are the
Giants I consider the Giants to be the
deity race from the original game they
were the ones who found the Lord souls
within the first flame and eventually
came to rule from anor londo a palace
designed for giants while some of them
are giants in the stereotypical sense of
the word many of them have the power to
manipulate their size depending on their
power and I think this is what makes
them Giants so why would these giants
have crossed the sea to another land in
the timeline of the chosen Undead the
light from the first flame is fading the
world is getting darker colder and
lordran seems to be at the center of it
all the lords are losing their influence
in the world with their power being
sustained by the illusion of life and
light in Anor Londo
among humans our curse is spreading that
turns humanity insane and most of the
human lands you visit are overrun by
Hollow soldiers or demons so what are
the Giants to do we'll remember the
description of the ring of the Sun
princess from Dark Soul says this the
princess of sunlight Guinevere
left an Orlando along with many other
deities driven out of their crumbling
Kingdom
perhaps drangleic is the land the Giants
fled to but regardless whether Guinevere
and the other lords were the Giants who
cross the sea to Drang lake it seems
that the
giant sparked a war in drangleic that
collapsed this kingdom as well the
kingdom of drangleic was ruled by King
vendrick a just king who gave
high-ranking appointments to Knights who
demonstrated their valor and charity
distinguished warriors were granted the
Royal soldiers ring which increases the
load that can be carried the King
favored the Warriors who staked every
battle on their strength alone and the
kingdom was led to prosperity
the official retinue to the King were
his halberd wielding Dragon Riders it
seems like dragons will be playing a
part in the law of dark souls - are they
the same dragons descended from the
ancient dragons they were extinct in the
original game but it seems like they
were returning now or maybe they've been
in drangleic all along or maybe they're
wyverns are descendent of dragons it's
impossible to know at this point so what
caused the collapse of the drangleic
Kingdom perhaps we'll meet the king in
Dark Souls 2 the trope of a fallen or
corrupted King has always been present
in the souls games and I feel like he
might have the answers moving on let's
talk about the story focus of Dark Souls
2 the focus of Dark Souls 1 was on
humanity and the fading flame while
frampt promises that linking the flame
will undo the curse of the undead
it doesn't seem logical the length of
fire ending of the first game just means
that the flame will last a bit longer
with you burning in Gwynn's place and
the Dark Lord ending still means that
the flame will fade eventually I believe
both endings lead towards the same end
and that the flame is still fading in
Dark Souls 2 in the first game we have
absolutely no closure on what caused the
curse many knights ventured into lordran
in order to find out what caused the
curse like the Knights of Boulder and
Beranek but nothing was really
discovered except that the first flame
was fading in Dark Souls 2 it's been
confirmed that there will be a huge
focus on the curse the curse of the
undead the dark sign almost every human
you meet in the series is afflicted by
the curse destined to die over and over
until they go insane and Hollow but how
do you become cursed what spreads it is
there a cure
I believe these will be the questions we
explore
Dark Souls 2 in fact we're already
seeing this emphasis like a moth drawn
towards a flame your wings will burn
over and over again as you continue to
hollow you will lose your souls again
and again to the soul starved hollows
that are instinctively drawn towards
them expect this sort of thing to be a
theme in the next game to cut this video
off I am going to read some of the more
fascinating item descriptions from the
beta I hope you enjoyed please leave a
like and try to contribute something
meaningful to the discussion down below
alright let's read some descriptions
throw lightning this one should be
familiar this miracle came into the
possession of the Melfi enclosure
through ancient law little is understood
about the source of its power
perhaps this miracle belonged to some
long-forgotten hero he reckon you know
who they're talking about
the next one is hunter's hat and this
one also should remind you of someone
favored by hunters skilled with a bow
this hat was based on the one worn by a
folkloric master archer whose name is
now lost to time the reason I think this
hat indicates it's a sequel is not
because Faris is in Dark Souls but
because the name of Pharisees lost to
time in Dark Souls 2 but it's not lost
to time in Dark Souls 1 the next one is
the key to the prison in the Huntsman
scopes the undead hunts during the reign
of the iron King took place in this
forest and the cells in which the undead
were held still stand there to this day
however the march of time has eroded any
difference between the captors and the
captives and I put this one in there
just because I thought it was really
interesting about the iron king and how
they're still hunting the undead I think
it's strange that the undead are still
seen as such a plague when really
blocking them away doesn't ever do
anything I mean they locked them away in
Lordran
in the undead asylum and that did
borderline nothing to curb anything so
anyway the next one is the life gem a
small stone made up of crystallized
souls gradually restores a small amount
of HP these stones are often found next
to corpses as such is the case perhaps
one could call this item the dead husk
of a soul on rare occasions one might
find a life gem that emits a
particularly strong light it seems the
power of the owners soul is apparent
even in such a husk and I thought this
one was interesting just because it
explains what life gem is its
crystallized souls and souls of the
essence of life in dark souls so it
makes sense this heals you I suppose all
right human effigy an effigy formed from
a lump of an unknown black material it
is surprisingly warm and strangely soft
to the touch use this item to reverse
hollowing when gazing closely at the
effigy one starts to perceive a human's
appearance it is said that the
appearance you see is your own true form
and I put this one in just because
obviously human effigies are a really
important mechanic they basically
replace humanity and they aren't really
telling us anything new but I thought it
was interesting
Estus flask this reinforces the idea
that the game is a sequel there is a
kind of link between the estus flasks
and the bonfires that illuminate the
world of the undead but knowledge of
this has been long forgotten all that is
known now is that this flask remains a
prized possession of the undead next
homeward bone fragment of an undead bone
used as fuel for bonfires return to the
last bonfire rested at this bone
belonging to an undead whose journey was
cut short as the mysterious power to
travel to bonfires it's almost as if it
seeks to continue its journey and I put
this one in just because it sounded
almost poetic you know an undead journey
cut short that's why it actually
teleports you back to the bonfire
the darksign are really important part
of the game like a moth drawn to a flame
those branded with the dark sign are
fated to be consumed over and over again
this is the only fate permitted to them
now I wonder if that's just wording or
if you know fate permitted to them
almost sounds like someone's controlling
their fate so that's an interesting
thing to think about and the last one
will leave you with imperial great
shield a certain man's favorite great
shield forged by layering thin sheets of
iron it provides excellent defense for
its weight perhaps you'll learn more
about the original owner when next you
meet now I could be wrong because I
can't remember what this shield look
like in the game but you know I think
this could be the shield of patches he
always uses a really light great shield
keep an eye out for him I guess anyway
thanks guys for watching I'll catch you
in the next one
we see the struggle of others unfold
around us as they fight for the things
important to them there's a man who
fights on behalf of his broken homeland
another who fights to prevent his
kingdom being broken one man believes in
research for the sake of knowledge and
maybe this knowledge will give you the
power to fix your mistake with this
power you may have to do terrible things
to many